what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so getting into Green Lantern recharge
really a screen Lantern core recharge
but much like Green Lantern vol 1 this
is really just kind of a refresher on
what the Green Lantern Corps are about
but Jeff while Geoff Johns did write
this issue he actually won't write
consistently right the Green Lantern
Corps instead his main emphasis will be
on Green Lantern but the cool thing
between the relationship with these
characters is that it's almost the
opposite from what we're seeing in DC
rebirth right now for example if you're
reading DC rebirth how Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps deals with the Green
Lantern Corps out in space Green
Lantern's deals with Simon Baz and
Jessica Cruise on earth this is the
opposite simply because of the fact that
when the Green Lantern landscape was
relaunched by Geoff Johns that what he
did is he focused on Hal Jordan under
the Green Lantern banner on earth and
the Green Lantern Corps dealt with space
so it's actually kind of a cool concept
but those are the guys who picked up Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern Corps number
one and felt baffled by what was going
on with regards to all the stuff that
was taking place and all those
characters a lot of that is going to be
fleshed out here in the Green Lantern
Corps line of stories now these will
intersect when we get into like revenge
of the Green Lantern's when we get into
like Sinestro Corps war a lot of the
crossover events how Jordan and the
Green Lantern Corps will simply come
together for the duration of that story
and it'll be that way for quite some
time there are stories like like mr. the
Star Sapphire things like that that will
focus largely on how Jordan and Carol
fares but the fact remains here the Jeff
Jones is a really good job of
intertwining these two stories together
for the purpose of giving us a full
fleshed out idea of what the Green
Lantern mythos is about now the way this
kicks off is simply with the death of a
new Green Lantern I mean I guess is
appropriate the last time we had the
Green Lantern landscape Hal Jordan kill
them all when he declared himself to be
parallax but with regards to this what
we find out is there are some stars
around the cosmos that are basically
going supernova and those stars
exploding are resulting in the formation
of a black hole which are either sucked
in Green Lantern's in and killing them
or transported in the different
locations or else simply exploding and
killing Green Lantern's in the explosion
before they actually turn into black
holes but what John's does is he sets
the stage for splitting up Hal Jordan
and the rest of the Green Lantern's the
reason why I say that is because of the
fact that Hal Jordan well in the middle
of a test pilot mission is approached by
Guy Gardner and Guy Gardner basically
says look all the Green Lantern's except
for you are being recalled back to OA
and the reason why is because of the
fact that there still have to be
your lanterns that are protecting their
own sector and one of the ways of Geoff
Johns gets away with a really good way
with this is by simply saying that with
regards to the planet Earth there's like
for Green Lantern's there's those Hal
Jordan there's Jon Stewart there's Guy
Gardner and there's Kyle Rayner and so
they have three more Green Lantern's
than they actually need not to mention
that how Jordan is the greatest of all
the Green Lantern's and so the guardians
of the universe and kind of get away
with letting him stay on earth and
recalling most of the people there but
the reason why Kyle Rayner is leaving
the reason why Jon Stewart's leaving and
the reason why guy gardner is leaving is
because of the fact that the guardians
are consolidating a bulk of the Green
Lantern Corps back to OA for the purpose
of recreating the Green Lantern Corps
itself now at this point we switch over
to a person by the name of cirrhotic not
to know so Roenick is as you guys know
right now in house run on the Green
Lantern Corps she basically took over
the leadership role of the Sinestro
Corps following the death of Sinestro
and she's one of the individuals
alongside Jon Stewart who was
instrumental in combining the course
together but when the the comics made
reference to the idea that cirrhotic was
a Green Lantern at one point in time
this is what they're referencing what
happens is he's basically in the middle
of surgery she's actually on a planet
korugar and she's immediately provided
with a Green Lantern ring of course the
reason being because of the fact that
there's a whole host of new lanterns
that are being offered positions now
what we'll find out is the reason behind
this being the Guardians basically took
away the notion of there being one Green
Lantern per sector and they're actually
gonna have two green lanterns per sector
but what ended up happening here is that
because of couriers history with
Sinestro basically becoming corrupt with
power imposing his own will and his own
dictatorship really in this sector more
than any other Green Lantern's are
looked down upon
they're frowned upon and people who
become or really kind of inducted into
the Lantern Corps are basically
individuals who are kind of ostracized
from society until such a time that they
come back without the Lantern ring now
one of the other things that Geoff Johns
establishes here is that just because a
person is inducted into the Green
Lantern Corps does not mean that they're
required to stay there instead they can
vacate they can walk away from being a
Green Lantern at any point in time now
of course again once you see that play
out with ceramic here in a second but
what we do is they basically just jump
to a handful of different sectors these
aren't wildly important issues different
individuals who are basically becoming
rain lanterns but the reason why Jeff
jobs included this little
Tippett here in the stories because what
it shows us is that so long a person has
the ability to overcome great fear they
can become a Green Lantern and so
individuals who were engaged in you know
bloody civil wars and different things
like that if they have the power to
overcome great fear they will become a
Green Lantern so it's not like the
hammer fork right it's all you have to
have certain attributes so you know five
or six different attributes that allow
you to wield the hammer the green
lantern rings are far more simplistic
than that the reason why is because of
the fact that when the Guardians formed
the Green Lantern Corps they knew it had
to be a mishmash of individuals who
would hold loyalty to the Green
Lantern's they wouldn't turn against the
Green Lantern's but also they knew some
of these individuals needed to know how
to fight they needed to have a history
of warfare they need to have a history
of engaging in different conflicts so
what we end up doing is they basically
follow Kyle Rayner and Guy Gardner back
to the planet OA now for them this isn't
new I mean they've been here before on a
multitude of occasions but for them it's
also you know kind of interesting to see
the Green Lantern Corps being reformed
and its ranks being expanded and so of
course there's all measure of different
creatures here in order to you know who
are going to be inducted into the ranks
and some of these critters look outright
just weird man like it is like if some
of these critters look crazy they're uh
there's a wild folk if one most like a
giant slug it's it's crazy to see how
some of these folks look but uh but the
fact remains here you know what these
ranks being expand is what's basically
being done here is really it picks up
with the idea of different people who
are going to be playing out different
roles but a lot of them come from their
own backgrounds and so some of the funny
things here is that some of these
individuals hail from like warring
planets of to members of different
societies who've been waging war against
one another and that's what creates an
interesting dynamic in the realm of the
Green Lantern mythos is because of the
fact that there are some people who are
part of races and their races have a
blood feud and they've been fighting for
for millions of years but they have to
put those blood feuds aside for the
purpose of working cohesively as Green
Lantern's so that's what I say this work
so well is because the rule of the Green
Lantern Corps is it doesn't matter where
you hail from your loyalty is to the
Corps first and then to the rest of the
universe second and so if you're in the
middle of engaging in a conflict on your
own planet and you're recalled back to
the back to OA by the guardians of the
universe you drop what you're doing and
you go back to OA that's the expectation
that's given to you now we're also
reintroduced to the character of salaat
as the last kind of light
this administrator so to speak for the
Green Lantern Corps which is to say he
kind of speaks on behalf of the
Guardians directly to the other lanterns
of course the Guardians themselves are
very very isolated from the rest of the
Green Lantern Court but one of the funny
things is the Jeff jobs immediately
establishes that there are some
individuals out there who do not see
this as a good thing they do not see the
guardians of the universe being isolated
as something intrinsic instead they see
it as something that could be nefarious
no one really knows what the Guardians
are planning back then so in truth it
really all just comes down to whether or
not you believe the Guardians are
inherently good guys and because of the
history of the Green Lantern Corps there
are a lot of those out there who do not
they look at how Jordan when he declared
himself parallax and tried to destroy
all existence they look at Sinestro when
he became a bad guy they look at the
history of the Lantern cores and say
these are individuals who are inherently
corrupted these are individuals who were
inherently bad and the Lantern Corps
does not do us any favors now of course
Jeff Jones will basically adjust these
stories in a way to where it will expand
a lot of mythos on the Lantern Corps
that's how a lot of people look at them
within the DC universe now the other
half of this and the reason why the
guardians are in such a state exclusion
is because the fact but they've been
analyzing all these different stars that
are being converted into black holes the
biggest question to them is why one of
the world is going on here that Green
Lantern's are missing the Green
Lantern's are vanishing so on and so
forth now something else to point out
here is that this instance of
individuals who can basically walk away
from being Green Lantern's comes in the
form of sorana can remember because of
the packet Sinestro made kur over a
dictatorship like planet basically ruled
over it with an iron fist cirrhotic is
one of several individuals who
absolutely of boors lanterns and so
despite the fact that she's been chosen
she basically says I am NOT going to
choose the path of the Green Lantern I'm
going to leave and so she basically just
bails out and so of course she tells her
ring
take me back at which point the
presumption is that when she got back
home she would basically release her
ring and say go choose somebody else you
know go find somebody else who is I was
capable now the reason why ironic holds
this idea isn't necessarily just because
of the fact that Kruger had become such
a dark place but because of the fact of
her own ties to Sinestro as sinestro's
dotted so because of that her biggest
fear is that she will basically fall
down the path of becoming a bad guy
she'll fall down the path of becoming
Sinestro and that really is the biggest
fear of almost anybody on
River itself now from here things are
pretty straightforward in the fact that
we basically have the new members of
lanterns learning how their powers work
the various training sequences that go
on we're going to need a montage the the
little training sessions and so on and
so forth but also the idea that that a
lot of these individuals too may see
themselves as people who are kind of
above the law but they exist to maintain
order within their sector and to ensure
the safety of those who reside within as
it was basically the Green Lantern Corps
saying you do not exist above the law
your your loyalty is to the Lantern
Corps after the Lantern Corps your
loyalty is to the betterment of
everybody in your sector not just one
particular planet which is really the
the fate that befell Sinestro once the
nest really became a bad guy because he
simply came to the believer came to
realize that his own planet was the rift
of order and structure and Surrey chose
to impose that paying more attention to
his sector or to his planet
then he did the rest of this sector now
again you know with these various
individuals is kind of hanging out
monitoring these stars making sure that
nobody comes across them different
things like that playing just as much of
a humanitarian role as a police role
some of these individuals they end up
seeing these stars explode and lose
their lives in the process now of course
the reason why is because the explosion
of these stars kind of takes them by
surprise but even these stars going
supernova happens in a matter of seconds
it doesn't happen over the course of
days or hours or anything along those
lines and so one of these instances of a
couple of the lanterns getting carried
away with their powers come in the form
of two individuals who basically witness
a Santa guard ship coming past now with
regards to this ship passing by them
ended up happening is they basically
boarded it they got carried away and
said you know we're the police here
we're the ones who run the show you have
to answer to us let us board your ship
you know of course this happens after
they tell the ship to turn away and the
ship says no that they're on a mission
of mercy that kind of thing so again
it's kind of a cool scenario but
ultimately they're sucked into this
black hole and the question is well
where do they go next well they're
effectively being held in stasis and
what's actually happening here is that
what's in these black holes are
basically the spider rays like blood
enemies of the guardians of the universe
and so what this does is it sets the
stage for the next half of the story
with like Kilowog basically the drill
instructor for the Green Lantern
answering a call for aid arriving to
where these lanterns out after he was
pulled into the black hole and is
basically this realization that there
isn't
our organism there's an entire race of
people that exist inside these like
holes not only that these aren't simply
just holes instead what they are are
basically you know subspace networks you
know when these stars are turned into
black holes they're literally just kind
of removing the star out of the way and
they're opening up a hole in space and
time it allows them to move all
throughout the universe at you know
we're I guess really super speed isn't a
phrase I would want to use but it's the
best way I know how to describe it but
basically it's kind of like creating
shortcuts is really what black holes are
you know with shortcuts in space but the
fact remains here that with these
various lanterns facing off against
these various threats again it's only a
handful of them it's really not the
entire core but again this is also met
with the arrival of a handful of bounty
hunters so again Geoff Johns is kind of
throwing a lot of things at us this is
really done for the purpose to show us
what all goes on in space and that's
kind of the beauty of it is because of
the fact that the Green Lantern Corps
does not just face off against one
villain and they defeat that villain and
they face up against the next and they
face off against the next it's not a
linear thing the Green Lantern Corps
will face off against a multitude of
villains all at the same time or one
immediately right after the other and
sometimes they'll even overlap towards
the tail end of one conflict another
will crop up and what this does is it
shows us as the reader that adds Green
Lantern's they have to be able to
multitask they have to be able to rely
on their teammates they have to be able
to recognize there are some folks out
there who just want to destroy stuff and
there are some folks out there who just
want to kill Green Lantern's because
keep in mind you know with regards to
the to the to the mythos out there it's
not basic it's not a simple thing
there's a lot of really deeper roots
here Geoff Johns invokes the notion that
there's collateral damage there are
people out there who have been killed in
fights between the Green Lantern's and
other people are they've lost loved ones
in fights between the Green Lantern's
and other individuals and because of
that there are people out there who want
vengeance against the Green Lantern
Corps there are some individuals out
there who just have bounties on members
of the Green Lantern's as a result there
are all kinds of different facets with
regards to those individuals who swear
you know violence against the Lantern
Corps who want to see the Lantern Corps
destroyed who want to see them brought
to an end but again ultimately what this
does is it basically has you know
Kilowog Guy Gardner Kyle Rayner a
handful of other ceramic all fighting
their way out of this you know whole
spider race and eventually making their
way free the problem with this is that
as time progresses the more they fight
the more they use their Lantern wings
this wouldn't necessarily be a horrible
issue but there
not able to draw their own batteries to
them and so because of that they can't
charge their rings so they're basically
fighting with a lifeline now by the time
they make it out they do so you know in
order to basically draw their draw their
lanterns out and keep themselves alive
oh of course what this does is it still
begs the question what is this fighter
ace doing and what's their intention
with destroying the guardians of the
universe and how are the how are the
lanterns going to respond well the
lanterns respond in the exact way that
we would expect because remember because
of the fact their loyalty has to be held
directly to the protection of the
universe the Guardians of the Universe
and Ouma itself before all else what
this does is it basically has how Jordan
and it has Jon Stewart arriving on the
scene now this is cool the way that
Geoff Johns does is in a way that is
drawn out is awesome because it is
basically Jeff Johnson hey look we have
all these new guys out there and sure
you have guy gardner and sure you have
cow wayne or who's still you know i on
this particular point in time but
there's those guys and then there is Hal
Jordan and there's Jon Stewart a cut
above the rest now depending on who you
talk to some people will get mad if you
say that though no no you know Kyle
winters better than Jon Stewart or Guy
Gardner is better than Jon Stewart
although say some of those guys are
better than Hal Jordan but that's the
beauty of this story is because one it
gives us the cord in and of themselves
but two it also asks us as the reader
which green lantern is the best one
which is the question I'm asking you
which green lantern do you think is the
best uh but in my mind I think I think
Hal Jordan is probably the best of the
best of all the Green Lantern's you know
his character and the fact that he's
kind of veiny and carefree and the fact
that he really rough around the edges
but has it where it counts that's one of
the things that I love about his
character so much but ultimately what
this does is it leads to to the fact of
this spider race is basically going to
invade the guardians of the universe
home planet and essentially destroy them
all suck the entire thing into a black
hole that's kind of this last-ditch
effort to eliminate the Guardians in
their entirety now the spider guild
itself is not wildly important here what
is actually important is a group called
the Saiyans of Vega and that was one of
the things that I kind of wanted to wait
until this point to really bring up with
regards to John's entire landscape one
of the things that he establishes here
is again the idea of collateral damage
with regards to this network with regard
to these you know low black
so on and so forth what it did is when
they rescued cirrhotic it required dye
gardener kyle rayner a handful of others
to enter the vegas system but what we
found out was that over the course of
their existence that's a guardians of
the universe and the vegans or evasions
or you know they didn't people whatever
you want to call them they have
basically created a pack you know you
stay away I stay away and the neutrality
will be maintained where the Green
Lantern's cross again this violates that
neutrality and so what it does is it
sets the stage for possible retribution
now that's one of the reasons why this
is so significant is because Geoff Johns
makes this just as much about water
skirmishes as he does about the Green
Lantern's patrolling their sectors and
keeping the universe protected and
that's why it's so cool is because again
it's not just this linear thing it's not
just and that we fight this guy for five
issues and then the story's done there's
a lot of complicated plot devices
there's a lot of character development a
lot of complex stuff that goes on here
which is why it's so cool the great
thing about what geoff johns does is he
paces it out in a way that is easy to
understand and of course even then once
geoff johns leaves and the titles taken
over by Dave Gibbons is taken over by
Peter Tomasi is taken over by these
various guys that pacing out of the
Green Lantern mythos will still be
maintained and it'll still be easily
digestible stuff which is one reasons
why people love this run so much is
because it's not overly complicated and
that's why I still say you know that for
the most part when it comes to the Green
Lantern mythos it's all about having to
read it in its entirety it's not really
something you can kind of pick and
choose because it creates a more
cohesive story if you do because then
you find yourself caring about
characters that you wouldn't have really
cared about before now for a year things
wrap up pretty fast and again this one's
kind of funny is because of the fact
that we would expect well divisions
coming after you with the the Green
Lantern's basically invading today in
space that it would lead to this oh my
god this whole second huge major event
but instead that doesn't happen what
they end up doing is basically using the
power of their rings a conjunction with
the central power battery to essentially
take the energy of this Sun that's going
supernova and send it right back through
this black hole network has been created
by the spider gills and destroy the home
base of the spider guilt but that's why
this is interesting is because again
jon's doesn't say okay hey here's like
this self-contained story and that's it
it's not just a series of closed stories
that are all basically one shots what we
end up getting is just this ongoing
thing that will have this this little
notion introduced that well maybe the
vagus will come back for the
and then at some point along the line
they do so you kind of have to harken
back to Green Lantern Corps vol 1 with
this story recharge in order understand
why that's happening now at the same
time it's also kind of self-contained in
to some degree in the sense that you
know you can really just sort of read
though you could read you know brightest
day by itself and be fine but again it
just kind of creates more of a cohesive
story so that really kind of wraps
things up pretty fast in terms of you
know the Green Lantern Corps it's not
really about giving us this major event
instead it's about setting the stage for
the character so while the spider guild
is essentially obliterated you know why
their home bases is more or less
destroyed what this does is it basically
ends with this reformation of the Green
Lantern Corps it ends with the guardians
of the universe saying it's time that we
stop being recluses and it's time that
we basically step out into the universe
and people come to fear us and it's also
basically saying hey look here is what
you're going to find everybody else but
sighs Hal Jordan so again it's kind of
cool here but with regards to the
Guardians themselves this is also
intriguing because it's basically John's
saying hey look the other Guardians
served to protect the universe but they
can be pretty nefarious and they're
dubious and sometimes they're full of
lies and the fact that they don't reveal
everything to the Green Lantern's will
come back to haunt them so again it's
really him kind of setting the stage at
least the very early days for stories
like wrath of the first Lantern and
things like that you know revealing
these little bits and pieces of
information over the course of his
entire Green Lantern run essentially
saying the Guardians are not too benign
individuals that you thought they were
they're pretty dark they're not really
trustworthy but again this also
basically ends with ceramic effectively
taking up her role as a Green Lantern so
for those of you guys who were reading
how Jordan the Green Lantern Corps right
now again you know you you'll probably
kind of interested about psionic you may
be kind of a position like who is this
girl what's the deal with her this will
cover the story the progression of her
character leading up to Robert and
Eddie's current work with the idea of
Hal Jordan the Green Lantern's and her
essentially taking over the Sinestro
Corps at the behest of Sinestro leading
up to the moment right now in the realm
of DC rebirth but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to come let's
explain make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the rod core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I love Geoff Johns
Green Lantern it's crazy
and anyway guys I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you